so this is garnets universe that was
random yeah y'all go first on this one
um no I don't want to walk the glory oh
and be Hawking it on all the kindness
that I let you start and talk about this
one because there's so much interesting
stuff to talk about um I liked the bit
where amethyst um
killed Stephen and then pearl brought
them back and then garnets like let's
eat cake and that's what they did okay I
didn't watch it I'm not sure I entirely
did either this one was weird
uh III did see it I um it just is a
story told from Steven's point of view
and it's not a point of view is just
imagining what happened yeah cuz he
doesn't see any garlic and it's as weird
as it sounds yeah um it's just a little
strange enjoyed the animation it had a
vague kind of it was like Samurai Jack
crust with so mushy and DBZ in a new
Yasha like a little bit of like there's
actually a anime thrown in and there's
nods to Mario in there there's not it yo
Socky yo Jimbo is in there pretty nice
just like hey it's yo Jimbo um but uh
yeah ah I cringed when Ringo came in um
it even that I'm sure guys a fine voice
actor does other stuff but even when he
starts talking don't you just kind of
check out something about that character
he's just not sure even when he's not
that character I know but I obviously
heart obviously he strikes some sort of
chord with you know it's just so funny
how it's just anything around him even
when he's talking I'm just like and I'm
not interested I'm not interested what
what what did I miss I'm sorry I was not
the trusted it like and it's already in
the sour episode um I mean he wasn't
like the worst choice he's a very
this is a very cute episode um I don't
have I don't think there's much else to
say but that I I did like that Stephens
hiding from garnet and again now my
favorite part there was a lot of kind of
like parental kind of like you know it
got very cute and we don't we don't see
them having like family moments often um
so I liked that I like the fact that he
kind of told this store and I like the
fact that in the story garnet or Steven
means a lot to garden that there was
something about the way she kept looking
at that picture just like don't worry
Steven oh come back then when he turned
it into the onion ring I was like oh it
did like my I did like my jaw drop
there's just uh thanks um I couldn't
believe what I was seeing there I was
like oh you dick hit like but I
don't know a party like part from those
things that is just sort of a cute story
told from teeth Stevens point of view so
I I was thinking to myself like they're
the whenever she did something that sort
of reminded you this is Stevens story
like you know have you told about us yet
no I must not let him know that my
friends are secretly fluffy animals he
cannot know something that awesomer say
it's like little things like that I kind
of like it hair yeah but it's and even
but no Steven is too awesome and too
wonderful and I must do it for you
Steven away you know again it's like
those little things are nice touches the
story itself
um yeah bizarrely I didn't get that into
and I don't know I was hoping to maybe
enjoy a Cavill on the same level of like
the story be original I avatar in Korra
or like even in home movies where most
of the episode is just one of their home
movies where it's like there's evil and
yeah uh George Washington away evil int
Oakley and style your mare that the star
boy episode I was kind of hoping it was
gonna be something like that a star boy
let's go find out how how yeah where
it's just so strange is so R and ever
seen home movies is one of the greatest
shows that Iran I want my favorite shows
God each damn Benjamin's in it you
should watch yeah I like early I know my
small yeah well one of his beginning
roles and just so I would say BAE was
post dr. Katz yeah oh I always go to dr.
K's for his popularity search start
though because everyone's favorite
character oh it's come coach McGirt
okay yeah um but uh yeah it's like if
there was a way to either keep cutting
back to Steven telling the story or a
reaction or something I feel like there
need to be something else or it was
narrating it there was a narrator at the
end I was like it was it was like a
deeper voice right which is interesting
now wonder a boy actor was like so see
when I talk to see ways to make it
high-pitched and that's as normal that's
an or voice or as he make it lower did
they slow the pitch down yeah now I'm
really curious as well cuz the narrator
version sounded like just a normal voice
yeah maybe uh so yeah I'm curious about
that but yeah it's one of those things
where it's like I felt like this there
was a missing element there's like one
other missing component I felt like
wasn't there and it's hard to say what
it is that could have made this like
actually a really funny really good
episode uh and but for what is it's
likes it it's cute it's good even the
cute value I thought had the most at the
beginning though when she comes in and
yeah I'm like I thought that was very
warm that was very nice these three have
been in a row been weird yeah the last
one I think is my favorite a set of
three
oh that's saying something give it
Steven universe yeah the last getting
weird the last one was definitely the
best mmm I kinda liked first one was the
worst there was one more again oh oh
that was before this one gotcha I'm
talking I'm talking about this three
that we've watched okay so one that we
watched before this episode is trilogy
extreme yes um but uh yeah like I say
there's one other element to make it a
little funnier like them you know coming
back to her reactor coming back to him
telling the story like there's not even
a narrator until the very end even the
narration that what made it I think a
lot funnier
um but yeah it's it's more strange than
Q but it's still cute you know
oh yeah so uh all right yeah there it is
um very very weird episode a very weird
couple of episodes we come across but uh
yeah it's um yeah like button hey Beth
Wilson they're all good but yeah good
it's good it's good yeah yeah that looks
good
yeah I heard Thanks they're dicks okay
thanks hey Brendan let's go see how hot
dogs are made let's do it captain of
outer space
I I don't know what pose to really your
clothes your paper would